For an added level of fun for fans, movies
and television shows have been known to include
easter eggs or subtle references that only
the most eagle-eyed viewers will find. But,
Disney and Pixar take easter eggs and hidden
details to another level. Here are Screen
Rant's 10 amazing hidden details in Disney
films.
Frozen Figures
Frozen catapulted to massive popularity with
help from the catchy and inspirational "Let
It Go," but the film also features a handful
of references to previous Disney and Pixar
movies, like Rapunzel and Flynn Rider from
Tangled attending Elsa's coronation. But you
have to look a lot closer to catch some of
Frozen’s other nods to Monsters Inc. and
Mickey himself. At Wandering Oaken's Trading
Post and Sauna, a wooden figurine of Mike
Wazowski can be seen sitting on the store’s
counter, while a Micky Mouse doll is hidden
on another shelf. Anna only decides to buy
winterwear – which was probably the right
call.
King Triton's Guests
A lot of Disney’s references in animated
classics or Pixar films, the studio will occasionally
add in a nod to other characters under the
Disney banner. In the scene in The Little
Mermaid when King Triton makes his entrance
in Atlantis to a room full of guests, many
have spotted Goofy and Donald Duck sitting
in the crowd. But, a second before they become
visible, Kermit the Frog is shown seated farther
back in the audience, recognizable by his
green collar. We can only wonder why the Mickey
and Muppets characters chose not to sit together…
Spinning Wheel
The folk tale Sleeping Beauty has been told
and retold for centuries, but one element
that never changes is princess pricking her
finger on the spindle of her spinning wheel,
sending her into a deep sleep. The spinning
wheel played a big part in Disney's version
too, with an evil witch behind the trap, before
Prince Phillip saved her entire kingdom with
true love's kiss. But the spinning wheel apparently
survived, since it can be seen in Rapunzel's
tower in the beginning of Tangled, connecting
the two stories of a Disney princesses trapped
by a witch.
Wreck-It Ralph Cameos
To populate the behind-the-scenes world of
arcade games in Wreck-It Ralph, animators
included tons of video game mascots and heroes.
Bowser, Pac-Man, Sonic the Hedgehog, Q*bert,
and Frogger all make an appearance. But, in
one wide shot of Game Central Station, two
characters unrelated to video games can be
seen: Vladimir, one of Tangled’s thugs in
the Snuggly Duckling Pub, and Maximus, the
proud palace horse are walking in opposite
directions in the station. There's also a
dinosaur that closely resembles Tiny the T-Rex
from Meet the Robinsons, and those are only
the easter eggs and cameos that fans have
actually spotted.
Charlotte's Storybooks
It's established early on in The Princess
and the Frog that southern belle Charlotte
La Bouff has an obsession with storybook princesses,
especially their dresses, which is how she
comes to be friends with Tiana, the daughter
of a seamstress. When Tiana kisses a frog
claiming to be a prince, and breaking the
spell accidentally makes a mess of Charlotte's
room, you can get a good glimpse of Charlotte's
book collection. If you look closely, one
storybook on a shelf is revealed to be Rapunzel,
the fairytale Disney's next princess film
would focus on in Tangled, giving a nod to
the following release.
Apple
In 1986, Steve Jobs purchased the Computer
Graphics Division from George Lucas's Lucasfilm,
establishing the independent company we now
know as Pixar. In honor of the man who also
founded Apple, Pixar has included nods to
the tech company or Jobs himself in a number
of films. Most notably, the titular robotic
hero of Wall-E makes the recognizable Mac
startup chime when he's done charging, and
Apple products like computers and iPods are
shown throughout Toy Story 3.Finally, after
passing away in 2011, the end credits of Brave
featured a dedication to Jobs in memory of
his contribution to Pixar. That last one may
not necessarily be hidden, but it's worth
mentioning.
Kristoff's Boogers
It isn’t that often that filmmakers include
messages in the credits, but aside from special
thanks, sometimes credits can be used for
one last joke. In the end credits of Frozen,
the filmmakers included a message to assure
audiences that Kristoff's assertion that “all
men eat their own boogers” is his opinion
only, and it does "not reflect the views or
opinions of The Walt Disney Company or the
filmmakers.” It seems Disney, like Kristoff,
takes the issue of ingesting nose mucus very
seriously.
Andy's Postcard
There are multiple theories circulating the
web about all the connections between Disney
and Pixar films, and certain easter eggs lend
more credence to these theories than others.
For instance, one shot from Toy Story 3 confirms
that the series' main human character, Andy,
exists in the same world as Carl and Ellie
Fredricksen from Up. If you look closely at
the bulletin board in Andy's room, there's
a postcard from the couple that includes the
address of their beloved yellow house, before
it's transported to South America, of course
(For some reason our version doesn’t have
this but I added Stills clearly showing it).
Nemo Takes a Swim
Disney's Brother Bear may not be as popular
or critically acclaimed as the studio's other
movies, but the animated feature focused on
the idea of family like many of Disney and
Pixar's films. Plus, Brother Bear features
a blink-and-you'll-miss-it nod to Pixar's
notably more popular 2003 release, Finding
Nemo, about a father searching for his son.
If you don't look close enough at the group
of salmon, it's easy to miss the clownfish
hiding among them. It seems Nemo wasn't lost
at 42 Wallaby Way, Sydney, Australia, but
swimming with salmon on the other side of
the world.
Tangled's Book Collection
Most of the hidden easter eggs inside Disney
movies only manage to reference one movie
at a time, but one shot in Tangled features
nods to three other princess films. When Rapunzel
and Flynn Rider are poring over an atlas while
at the festival of lights in Corona, books
referencing other films can be seen. One open
book displays the story from the opening sequence
of Sleeping Beauty, and two others are the
storybooks containing the tales of Beauty
and the Beast and The Little Mermaid. It's
unclear if Rapunzel has read the fairytales
of her fellow Disney princesses, but it's
a nicely hidden reference to their films.
So what did you think of our list?
Did we miss any hidden details in your favorite
Disney movies?
Let us know in our comment section below!
You should also check out our friends at TheRichest
and their new video we’re sure you will
love!
If you liked our video make sure you click
on the Subscribe button to get regular updates
and an amazing video library full of great
movie and TV facts!
Thanks!